there is only one war that matters the
Great War and it is here
hey everybody this is gonna be my finale
Q&A just careful for spoilers if you
haven't seen the episode yet still a
whole lot of questions about Tyrion I
think that they've answered a couple of
them I try to include that in this but
there will be a couple bonus videos
after this this week for the characters
but here we go first one will ask do you
guys think the Jaime and bran will get a
reunion well I think that they have to
at this point you had the Hound and
Brienne Jaime and bran would be one of
those really awkward moments a lot of it
just depends on where Jaime's headed
first is he headed for John and Daenerys
because they're headed for white Harbor
or is he headed straight to Winterfell
it makes sense that he tried to meet
with Team Daenerys first before anybody
went to Winterfell
so eventually they'll all be there in
bran isn't petty so it'll be more
awkward for Jaime than it will for bran
but I'll just be a fun payoff just to
bring it all the way back around from
him pushing him out that window
next one Minnie asks I thought the wall
was protected by strong magic against
the White Walkers and technically the
dragon is now a white Walker it kind of
doesn't make sense so the thing with the
wall is I think it's one of those things
where they just fast-forward over a plot
and they don't explain the logic of it
most likely scenario is that because
brain was marked he broke the magic seal
the way he broke the seal on the
weirwood tree that allowed them to get
in but in addition to the seal being
broken the night he needed something
powerful enough to bring down a portion
of the wall to bring the army through
it's so massive that they could probably
take down the gate at Eastwatch but what
happens is is they have a mechanism for
caving in that tunnel so there'd be no
way to get through for the army of the
Dead because they couldn't go around
because like they said in the episode
when Euron's like can they swim no they
can't swim so I think just in service of
moving things along as quickly as
possible they chose not to over explain
the logic of how the seal was broken
next one big tyrion question manu asks
why was Tyrion watching them have sex I
don't get why he was just waiting there
well so in the behind the scenes
Tyrion actually says that it won't end
well for everyone and he's really
worried about that that's kind of been
my takeaway is that he just really
worried it's gonna blow up in their face
it's dangerous for everybody involved
I'm sure it's good for both of them
in the moment but you don't even get the
relief of how beautiful it could be or
should be it's no it's just it's not
good but it should be but it's not it's
Game of Thrones it's a long history of
romance not ending well on this show
watching the cast react to that is kind
of funny but is interesting to see how
the characters will react to that next
question Chris asks what happened to
torment and beric so there are really
two likely scenarios and in both of them
they get away the first scenario is is
they just got down the wall before it
actually came down and they made it into
the bay or they just made it away the
second scenario is it that they ran the
other way along the wall to the next
castle and then made it down so either
way they're gonna be fine but what they
might do is they might have just gone
back to Castle black to tell Edie and
all the other people hate you don't need
to be here anymore because the army was
way over at Eastwatch they're headed
down to the last hearth
we need a rally with everyone else
because brain actually Ward the Ravens
he saw the wall coming down so
presumably brans gonna be the one to
send the Ravens out the wall has been
breached
everybody crap your pants and then get
your ass up here
next question sheep ass is Jamie still
commander the Lannister armies or did he
ride alone and where the hell is Gendry
so as for Jaime I definitely think that
Jaime rode alone because the Lannisters
are loyal to Cersei to the crown so you
know maybe a handful of people but I
think it's mostly just him as for Gendry
I know it's kind of a ragel situation
after episode 6 because at the end of
episode 6 after they're all escaping
when they get back to the wall and
Daenerys is waiting for Jon ragel isn't
anywhere to be found so presumably he
went back to Dragonstone so that's my
assumption for Gendry too because Gendry
is all about blacksmithing they're
making weapons it would make sense that
he's trying to help out back at
Dragonstone work on that stuff next one
savage ass who becomes king of both John
and Danny die so I'm assuming in your
question that they make it to the Iron
Throne and then they both die and there
is no child because their child if they
had one would be the next king what
would probably happen next is is in the
name of sanity they would call a Great
Council and they would appoint a new
king because you know Gendry does have a
small claim if he's a bastard and gets
legitimized but that'd be like putting
another Robert
the throne but remember that beerus is
all about putting someone who's best for
the realm on the throne so wouldn't
necessarily have to be someone who's
related by blood to John or Danny
next question Jordan asks did anyone
think that when maester aemon died he
was talking about John Aegon so you're
talking about eggs so the egg that he
was actually talking about was his
brother there's a series of novellas
that George R Martin has written called
tales of duncan egg egg is the egg that
Maester Aemon is talking about his name
was Aegon but he had several other
brothers maester aemon was his older
brother through circumstance maester
aemon became the next person in line for
the throne but he was studying to go to
the Citadel and he didn't want to start
another Blackfyre rebellion another
Targaryen Civil War so he abdicated his
right for the throne took the black and
it passed to his brother Aegon so that's
who the egg is so when he says egg
mother's calling you he's talking about
his brother egg when they were little
children like before all this craziness
happened next question fish plant says
Wilfs Golding was a really weird choice
of actor to play Rhaegar Targaryen I
know a lot of people were talking about
how he looked so close to Daenerys his
other brother and I think that was
definitely on purpose there were
actually a lot of people that thought
that that was Viserys but you have to
remember that they're related so they
would look alike
Rhaegar is just much taller much broader
soldiers you have to imagine that he was
a fighter so John takes after him so I
think they're just trying to keep a
little bit of continuity in their
families like they wanted the brothers
to look alike next question sir edge
Lord ass aren't you a Blackfyre if your
Targaryen bastard
so there are a lot of people that are
still confused by this so bastards are
named by region in by who you're born to
usually the father has naming rights so
if you're born in another region then
you can get another name that's why
brand said sand instead of waters which
is what bastards are called when they're
born in the crown lands so the black
buyers are actually an offshoot of the
Targaryen family they were made up of
bastards so that's why there's a little
bit of confusion but daemon Blackfyre
first of his name took that name because
of the black fire sword in this big
struggle over the succession so what
happened is is Aegon the fourth like
this big portly lurking guy he had many
many bastards he was sort of a Robert
Baratheon of his day he loved the
ladies and he loved his bastards too so
he had a son who was next in line for
the throne but his other bastard he
loved more so he gave him the ancestral
Targaryen blade black fire that's the
sword that we know Jon Snow now should
be wielding because he's next in line
for the throne but what happened is is a
bunch of the bastards got together
informed the black fires and then they
started fighting a war of succession
that turned into the Blackfyre rebellion
then they eventually lost were exiled to
Essos they formed the golden company so
the really cool thing is is if we're
actually gonna see black fire show up on
the TV show the sword it might show back
up with the golden company but I think
the more likely scenario with the golden
company on the TV show is there'll be a
couple black buyers but we'll see Daario
come back with them - next question
Seward asks I think that there were two
egg ons in the book it seems like the
show is merging Aegon young Griff
Targaryen and Jon Snow so actually just
to clarify that there's a lot of
confusion about this about the fake
Aegon I don't think that that's what Jon
Snow is meant to be on the TV show there
was a lot of confusion about who named
Jon Aegon was that Liana
all by herself or did Rhaegar have that
name in mind and tell her about it
before he left to go to the Trident the
most likely scenario and this is still a
theory but it's the best theory that
I've seen is that Liana wasn't really
aware of what was going on with regards
other family so she didn't know he
already had a son named Aegon and
because Aegon the conquerer was such
this big rallying figure in the history
of Westeros that's why she picked that
name because it was named with a lot of
meaning behind it but also because she
was not aware of family number one and
what was going on with them
so another follow up Aegon question
Patrick asks considering if John's name
is also a con in the books do you think
that he's going to be related to Danny's
vision in the house the undying so if
you haven't read the books Daenerys has
a vision they didn't do on the TV show
where she sees Rhaegar with a baby the
thing about that is that Daenerys has no
idea what Elia Martell looks like so she
just assumes that it was Rhaegar wife
because she knows about her history
because all the people that she's grown
up with a told her about her family so
when she sees this woman with the new
baby in Aegon and he says his song will
be a Song of Ice and Fire he's the
prince who's promised she might be
seeing Liana and just
realize it because the woman had dark
hair but elia martell also had dark hair
so there's a little bit of confusion in
the interpretation of the vision but you
know prophecies are mostly built on
metaphors next question Alistair asks
why didn't Littlefinger demand trial by
combat that is a good question how come
he didn't have any guards with him if
he's such a powerful person I think the
idea is is they just wanted to get rid
of him they're like this is the end for
him so they just wrote that into the
show this has been happening to
Littlefinger for the last couple of
seasons like why didn't he know Ramsay
was such a bad person the little finger
of the first couple of seasons as well
as the first couple of books sounds like
somebody who is amazing its sizing other
people up and knowing all the chess
pieces on the board and what's going on
the other example of that is the tyrion
character this season and all of his
terrible plans the reason why his plans
have probably been terrible because he
should be really good at this is because
they wanted Lannisters to have some wins
they wanted Cersei to win a couple
battles and they wanted to make Jaime
seem like a better battle commander so
that he could become their battle
commander in season eight up in the
north which is probably what's going to
happen with him but I'll do a separate
Jaime video about that Littlefinger is
just a casualty of the TV show rushing
plot along in needing to develop the
Sansa character so they really just
threw him under that bus so it's one of
those situations where by Dan and Dave
are great at adapting George R Martin
but when they have to originate
Littlefinger content like they had to
write original story for Littlefinger
they fall down a little bit so if you
have any problem with a Littlefinger
character the last couple of seasons I
would blame it on that but thank you so
much for so many questions these are
always a ton of fun to do
congratulations to the latest giveaway
winner to mix up please private message
me on the back end of my channel so I
can get your contact details my next
bonus video will probably be an Aegon
video just to explain why is so
important that that's John's true name
and who the other Aegon czar it gets a
little confusing but then I'll do some
more character videos like what's going
on with Tyrion there's a whole lot of
stuff we have to talk about but just
leave all your requests for bonus videos
in the comments below you can click here
for my season 8 predictions video and
you can click here for my finale video
again thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome I'll see you guys
tonight